well popular probiotics may not be as
helpful as you think and may even be
harmful
that's according to two new studies in
the journal Cell nearly 4 million
Americans take probiotics which are live
bacteria and hopes of boosting their
digestive health they can be taken as a
supplement or in foods like yogurt
sauerkraut and pickles researchers
studying the human digestive tract found
probiotics have questionable benefits
and may interfere with the body's own
natural ability to maintain gut health
our dr. David agus is with us and dr.
agus I drink a probiotic
Russian kefir every single morning
thinking that I'm not only continuing
the Russian heritage but also my body is
that not healthy I don't want to shock
your culture you have 30 feet of GI
tract
fionna and there are thousands of
different bacteria in them so taking a
couple of bacteria in that kefir is
probably altering that landscape that
rainforest of thousands of bacteria so
this was an amazing study because they
did endoscopy and colonoscopy they took
bacteria throughout the entire 30 feet
the first down if you will you know 10
yards of the GI tract and they looked at
these bacteria and when you took just
probiotics most of the time they just
went through you sometimes they stayed
but a couple of bacteria would dominate
then they did the amazing studies that
gave antibiotics and then the probiotics
and what happened is is that these
couple of bacteria in the kefir or the
pill they took actually started to
dominate the GI tract and it delayed the
normal bacteria from coming back so it's
not just it does no harm it could
actually delay recovery from antibiotics
which wiped out all the bacteria so is
that to say that the harm is related to
if you're taking it at the same time as
when you're taking an antibiotic which
some people have been told to do yeah I
mean that's what we think is that you
know antibiotics would wipe out bacteria
and the idea very simply was probiotics
are pills of live bacteria that can put
what we call beneficial bacteria in but
there are a few of the thousands of
species in that same study and I know
this is tough to do a morning television
but I'm gonna do it
they took the normal bacteria out of
individual and made a pill of their own
bacteria and they gave them to those
people and those people recovered in
days versus up to six months when they
took the probiotics so we're gonna have
personalized pills of bacteria going
forward and that's what's gonna be
exciting what is this that what does
this study say if anything about people
who take it when they're not taking
antibiotics because gut health has been
you know everywhere and and this has
been talked about a lot what does the
study say about so what it says it's gut
health is tremendously important the
data are right it controls your brain it
controls your immune system what you
absorb from food diabetes all of those
but a simple pill isn't a quick fix to
gut health and so we all want that quick
thing let me get better quickly and the
problem is there's complexity here and
we're just starting to learn an Obama
President Obama announced the human
microbiome project to look at these
bacteria in 2016 and so what we're
knowing is tenfold more bacteria in you
John than human cells and so there's
complexity there and so it's gonna take
a little while but gut health is going
to be a way we prevent disease and treat
disease in the future but the simple fix
of probiotics now is out the window no
simple fixes darn it you're a you're a
killjoy but that's all the time now I
have to read the killjoy that's all the
time we have thank god akhter